Trascrizione: Matteo Maggiò
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Secondo di tre fratelli, tutti maschi;
e i miei genitori molto giovani.
Mia mamma a dover gestire
questo quartetto al maschile:
anzi no, c'era anche il cane maschio,
quindi eravamo cinque.
Il principale strumento di gestione
di questo esercito al maschile
era il cucchiaione di legno,
quello dai mille usi:
tradizionalmente per mescolare cibo;
ma anche per indicare; per ricordare;
in alcuni casi, arma non convenzionale.
L'hai riconosciuta?
Bravo.
Ricordo un'infanzia molto bella,
ricca di affetto,
sebbene a quei tempi si mostrasse
in maniera indiretta.
Magari celata in un gesto,
in piccole rinunce,
in una merenda, in un ragù, in un caffè.
A proposito di merenda,
ricordo quando ero
studente alle elementari
e c'era il rito
dello scambio delle merende.
Quel panino speciale, la merendina nuova,
il compagno che non ne aveva.
Il bullo di turno che veniva lì,
e che te la strappava via;
e ogni tanto, il coraggio del gruppo
che interveniva e andava
a recuperare il maltolto.
Insomma, le relazioni attorno
a un panino e a una crostatina.
Scambiando le figurine e le biglie.
E con la voglia di giocare,
di confrontarsi.
Quella voglia di confrontarsi
che ho sempre mantenuto,
che ho sempre cercato
nel mondo del lavoro,
nei tanti ruoli che ho avuto
e nei tanti luoghi in cui sono stato.
In particolare, nel momento
in cui ci si relazionava a tavola:
quel luogo, quel posto in cui
ho costruito, consolidato relazioni;
ma anche festeggiato, e riso, e pianto,
in Italia e nel mondo:
Marocco, Uganda, Egitto, Stati Uniti,
passando per il Medio Oriente.
Al di là di cultura, religione e genere,
con tutti ho relazionato a tavola,
e in tutti i modi possibili.
Dal ristorante stellato al deserto,
in cui ricordo un momento
in cui abbiamo condiviso il cibo
in un unico piatto in dieci persone.
A una grigliata particolare nella giungla,
di cui non ricordo,
non so esattamente cosa ho mangiato;
e francamente, preferisco non saperlo.
Fino al Cairo,
dove mi sono rifugiato presso amici
nel bel mezzo della Primavera Araba,
durante i fatti di Piazza Tahrir.
Più o meno un anno prima
rispetto a quest'ultimo episodio,
era il 2010 quando,
alla ricerca di nuove strategie
per il mio business,
sono entrato in contatto
con la più grande organizzazione al mondo
di marketing relazionale.
E per chi non lo conoscesse,
è quel sistema per coltivare
relazioni di fiducia
e per poter arrivare a scambiare
opportunità di business.
E all'inizio, ho scelto queste strategie,
e queste tecniche, per il mio di business.
Ma di lì a poco, dopo pochi mesi,
ho scelto di farne la mia strada.
Imparare dai migliori al mondo
ogni tecnica, ogni strategia,
per poi applicarla e divulgarla in Italia.
In uno dei tanti momenti
di formazione in California,
dal cosiddetto padre
del networking moderno, Ivan Misner,
gli chiesi: Ivan, cosa ne pensi
del fare networking a tavola?
Lui sorrise, e mi disse:
"Claudio, fare networking
non è fare net-eating,
e neanche net drinking."
Però, a parte quella battuta,
si mostrò molto interessato alla mia tesi,
per cui se è vero che con metodo,
struttura, strategia,
si può passare
da un passaparola occasionale
a un passaparola strutturato,
e da relazioni superficiali
a solide relazioni di business,
dovrebbe essere altrettanto importante
porre la massima attenzione
a tutti quei momenti
in cui ci si relaziona a tavola.
E alla mia domanda specifica
se qualcuno avesse mai trattato
l'argomento con attenzione,
mi rispose: no.
E quindi, una vocina in me
disse: "È la tua occasione!".
E allora, iniziai a intervistare
migliaia di imprenditori,
di lì ai successivi nove anni.
E ciò che è emerso è stato, innanzitutto,
la voglia della maggior parte
degli intervistati
di relazionarsi a tavola.
E allora iniziai a catalogare
le loro risposte, e le mie impressioni.
E sulla base di quei dati,
a fare delle considerazioni
da cui ho tratto un'idea, e poi un metodo,
per strutturare il nutrire la relazione.
L'ho chiamato "Referral tasting"
E adesso, vorrei condividere con voi
qualche accenno su almeno tre punti.
Partendo proprio da un caffè.
Primo: in un incontro
di relazioni a tavola,
il dove è fondamentale:
quindi, l'attenzione al dove.
L'attenzione al dove -
immaginiamoci un ristorante.
Quindi, avete un incontro
in un ristorante di Milano?
È assolutamente differente
dal centro di Milano, magari,
alla periferia di Parma.
L'accessibilità?
Ci troviamo in una zona
a traffico limitato?
C'è la possibilità di raggiungere
la location con mezzi propri?
Mezzi pubblici?
Ci sono barriere
architettoniche a limitarci?
Queste sono solo alcune,
delle variabili da tener presente.
Giulio, assiduo frequentatore di un bar
del centro storico della città:
a suo dire, il miglior caffè al mondo.
E quindi, per degustare
questa prelibatezza
ci fece fare oltre un chilometro a piedi.
Peccato che le mie due colleghe
avessero i tacchi alti.
Ma per lui non era importante:
per lui era solo un caffè.
E ancora, attenzione
agli argomenti da trattare.
Parlare comunque liberamente,
tenendo presente chi hai di fronte
e gli obiettivi condivisi.
Mauro, appassionato cacciatore,
sempre pronto a raccontare
tutti gli aneddoti di caccia
nei minimi particolari.
E lo fece anche quel pomeriggio.
Peccato che eravamo con due persone
dichiaratamente animaliste.
Nostri potenziali clienti,
rimasti potenziali.
Ma anche per lui, era solo un caffè.
E poi, ancora,
l'attenzione alle verifiche.
Raccogliere, comunque,
sempre più informazioni possibili,
per poterci relazionare,
per poterci curare delle relazioni,
ma tanto è importante
raccogliere le informazioni
quanto verificarle.
Laura è sempre stata attentissima
al singolo minimo particolare.
E sapendo dei miei problemi
gastrointestinali,
si guardava bene dall'offrirmi un caffè.
Ma io in quel periodo stavo bene,
e francamente un buon caffè, quel giorno,
l'avrei bevuto più che volentieri.
I caffè arrivarono, eh, e profumatissimi:
per tutti tranne che per me,
che sorseggiai una tisana.
Ma anche per Laura,
nonostante la sua cura, solo un caffè.
Vedete come, anche partendo
da una abitudine semplice,
come prendere un caffè,
abbiamo analizzato
alcune piccole variabili
che possono modificare,
o stravolgere, l'esito di un incontro.
E con questo, impattare sulla relazione.
Il faro che guida, il viaggio,
in questo metodo è rappresentato
dalla "regola di platino"
del dottor Tony Alessandra,
che recita testualmente: "Tratta gli altri
come vogliono essere trattati loro! ".
Come vogliono essere trattati loro!
E questo ci guida in un percorso
di accoglienza, di ascolto.
Per poter arrivare a un giusto approccio,
e a scelte consapevoli.
Ma questo non basta:
va abbinato l'ascolto attivo.
Perché funzioni correttamente,
va abbinato l'ascolto attivo,
che è tra l'altro
il mettersi in accoglienza,
il porsi in accoglienza
e sintonizzarsi tanto sui contenuti
quanto su ragioni e sentimenti.
Nel raccogliere queste interviste,
è emerso qualcos'altro,
qualcosa di veramente illuminante.
Nutriamo noi stessi, e gli altri,
in modi e tempi di cui
non ci rendiamo conto.
E non sto parlando solo,
ed esclusivamente,
del cibo tangibile,
solido o liquido che sia.
Una parola gentile, la giusta parola,
in un silenzio in accoglienza,
la musica che ci fa sognare,
ma anche una pacca
sulla spalla, un sorriso.
Tutti ingredienti
con cui nutrire la relazione.
E ce ne siamo accorti tanto
lo scorso anno:
durante il primo lockdown,
in tanti, oltre al dramma della pandemia,
hanno vissuto momenti di paura.
E solitudine.
In quei giorni, tanti di noi
hanno imparato, anche,
ad utilizzare in maniera differente -
e in alcuni casi, più intensa -
strumenti di comunicazione on line,
anche per momenti conviviali.
E quindi abbiamo avuto
le colazioni on line,
abbiamo avuto gli aperitivi
con gli amici on line.
E i pranzi e le cene in famiglia.
Ricordo una cena, in particolare:
una cena con un amico.
Un amico che era in grande
difficoltà, in quel momento,
e che abbiamo scelto di invitare
a cena in famiglia in quella modalità.
Ricordo, soprattutto,
ciò che mi ha detto il giorno dopo:
"Sono stato li, ero con voi,
abbiamo condiviso tutto insieme".
Tutti gli ingredienti.
Sono tanti gli ingredienti
di cui ci si nutre.
Alcuni sono molto particolari:
altri sono, addirittura, magici.
L'ingrediente magico per eccellenza,
quello che non dovrebbe mai mancare
in ogni pietanza, in ogni ricetta,
è l'amore.
L'amore che è vita,
e può rendere speciale
ogni forma di nutrimento.
Mia mamma, che per prima mi ha nutrito,
mi ha insegnato a fare le cose con cura.
E a mettere quel magico ingrediente
in ogni pietanza, in ogni azione.
Ovunque.
Nei primi mesi di quest'anno,
abbiamo avuto modo di prenderci
un caffè al volo insieme.
Dedicarci qualche attimo.
Un caffè che conteneva più del solo caffè.
C'era quel "Ti voglio bene"
che non siamo mai riusciti
a dirci fino in fondo.
Quegli abbracci.
Oggi lei mi guarda e sorride,
ma da altri luoghi.
Ma c'è ancora in me
il suo ingrediente magico:
che magari ritrovo anche qui,
nell'aroma di questo caffè.
Vi invito a sperimentare:
che cosa vi fa stare bene?
Raccontatelo: che cosa vi fa stare bene?
Cosa mangiate per festeggiare?
Che peccato di gola vi concedete
per farvi una coccola,
magari in un momento un po' così?
Che cosa condividete
in un momento goliardico,
con gli amici e con le amiche?
Dove invitate il vostro miglior cliente,
o il miglior amico?
E ancora, come nutrite
il vostro tempo libero?
Sport?
Natura?
Arte?
Musica?
Che cos'altro?
Aggiungete un po'
di ingrediente magico, ovunque.
Nutrite voi stessi,
e nutrite gli altri, con amore.
Entrando in armonia gli uni con gli altri,
entriamo in armonia col mondo intero,
e tutte le creature che lo abitano.
Nutrire la relazione cambia la vita,
anche partendo da un caffè.
Grazie mamma.
(Applausi)